running everyone and welcome to the July
cabinet meeting for baver district
council this is the first of two cabinet
meetings today we're having the the
Baber
only subjects this morning and this
afternoon we will be having a
simultaneous cabin at me everyone mid
sufferer welcomes custody change live
plan cabinet meeting agenda apologies
for absence
good morning councillors I will call
your names in alphabetical order and if
you could indicate your presence for me
councillor Clive arfy present councillor
Dave Busby sorry council I don't believe
you've got your I think you're muted I
certainly was
Thank You councillor Derrick Davis yeah
councillor Michael Holt yeah councillor
Elizabeth Mel BC councillor mouthy C are
you a mute
councillor Mel VZ can you hear me
councillor mal vici can you hear me I do
believe you are on mute councillor mal
VZ sorry yes I am I lost everyone a few
minutes ago okay thank you yes counselor
John Osbourne yes here councilors Lee
Parker present counselor John Ward
present and we do also have councillor
Alastair McCraw with us this morning
present thank you thank you
next item declaration of interests by
councillors yes yes sorry I try to put
my hand up yes I do have one a
non-pecuniary in item 11 on the CCTV for
Sudbury and Hadley Thank You councillor
Osborn are there any others from anyone
nope right we'll move on then the next
item is paper BCA 1952 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 9th
of June 2020 I will go through those in
terms of the page number as shown in
modern gov so page 7 page 8 page 9 page
10 and finally page 11 does anyone have
any comments on any of those okay right
well I propose we adopt those minutes
may have a seconder please here we're
gonna put a hand up yeah I'll do it
Thank You councillor Parker and all in
favour
adopting the minutes yes yeah sure if I
could just do a roll call just don't
thank you so consular our fee sorry
counselor our thing are you on mute
I'm so sorry okay
Thank You counselor bust me for counsel
Davis or counselor Holt
Oh counselor male VC for counsel Osborne
for counselor Parker for an counsel
award oh thank you next item is to
receive notification of petitions in the
comments with the castle's petition
scheme yummy CJ thank you and next
questions by counselors again none
receive chair thank you and next matters
referred by the overview and scrutiny or
joint audit and standards committees
there were none thank you
moving on then the next item is the
forthcoming decisions list does anyone
have any comments about the items on the
forthcoming decisions list if not I'll
just like to draw your attention to the
cabinet meeting scheduled for August
there are two items currently on that
agenda one is a standing item for still
bids and the other is to do with the
sale of land in Sudbury in terms of the
sill bids this Paris still some work to
earn in terms of validating and so it's
more likely they'll come to before us in
September rather than August and
secondly there's been some delays on on
the lands Nayla Sudbury due to covert
and that again will likely to be ready
for September rather than August so
we're proposing that the August cabinet
meeting thinking of some of the items
picked up for the September agenda apart
from that I don't have any other
comments on the forthcoming two
list the case we will move on to the
next item on the agenda which is paper
BCA 1953 the general fund for national
our term for 2019 to 2020 so I'm pleased
to present report BCA 1953 the 2019 to
20 out turn for the general fund revenue
account and a general fund capital
program our strategic response to
financial challenges summarized in the
five key actions in paragraph 4.1 is
continuing to be successful however you
will see in paragraph 4.3 that the fair
funding review and business rates
revaluation have been postponed yet
again to 2022 due to the current crisis
although the impact of code 19 on the
2019 to 2020 budget was minimal you will
all be aware that its full impact on
local government finances will be
considerable we are still in the process
of understanding the cost increases and
income losses in the current financial
year and the impact on our medium-term
budgeting and paragraphs four point
seven to four point ten provides some
information about this we will monitor
the impact of code 19 as part of the
budget monitoring process during the
current year identifying any in your
actions that may be required and this
will form a significant part of the
considerations for the budget for 2021
to 22 and the updated medium-term
financial strategy we have had some
support from government just over nine
hundred and thirteen thousand pounds and
also four hundred and seventy six
thousand pounds of the hardship fund for
council tax relief and other support but
the total impact as you all have heard
in the recent briefing is substantially
more than that we do have sufficient
reserves to achieve a balanced budget
for 2020 to 21 but they will be severely
depleted and the picture beyond that is
more worrying significant actions may be
needed may need to be taken to ensure
financial stability in the long term and
you have already seen a list of proposed
actions that we will have to consider
last Thursday we also heard about the
additional support package to help with
loss of income from sales fees and
charges and to enable council tax and
business rates deficits to be spread
over three years rather than one we are
awaiting news of Steve
but this is very welcome used and it
looks to be a very reasonable settlement
from government right in terms of the
general fund revenue account this year
we do not have the benefit of the
one-off additional income we were
fortunate to have last year although we
prudently did transfer a considerable
amount of this to our reserves then this
year we will have an adverse variance of
two hundred and nineteen thousand pounds
the council tax collection rate remains
stable at just under ninety eight point
five percent if we are predicting a
significant fall this year we have not
chased debt for the first three months
of this year but are resuming this soon
in agreement with the shared revenue
partnership the business rates
collection rate also remain stable at
around ninety eight point six percent
but this too is expected to be affected
this year baseline business rates of 2.1
million a new house bonus of 0.7 million
were allowed for in the budget new host
bonuses fixed with the actual amount of
business rates does vary and this is
covered further in Section five point
ten the variations on expenditure in
income compared with a budget have been
identified and are presented in the
table in paragraph five point seven a
breakdown of the variances with
explanations is provided in Appendix A
and the explanations are reproduced in
paragraphs five point nine and 5.10 the
net as the most variance can be mainly
attributed to business rates 640
thousand pounds and reserves movements
of three hundred and two thousand pounds
offset by favorable variances of
planning fee income four hundred and
thirty nine thousand pounds their income
we received from the CCG for assisting
communities two hundred seventy five
thousand pounds and recharges to the HRA
of 198 hundred and fifty nine thousand
pounds and finally investment income of
a hundred thousand pounds it is worth
noting that expenditure on services is
generally in line with the budget the
latest position regarding the business
rates retention pilot but pilot projects
is provided in Appendix B we have
received 2.08
seven million pounds of saline come and
foreign deductions for expenditure and
the administration charge
above this has been transferred to the
reserve moving on to our reserves are
earmarked reserve movements as shown in
appendix D and excluding SIL show
decline from five point
5:09 million 25.0 for two million an
8.5% reduction as a result of the
silicum the the reserved pot now stands
at said six point three seven eight
million facility
tables one and two and section five
point one five show more detail for the
unmarked reserve transfers including the
business rates equalization reserve
business rates retention pilot
transformation fund and SIL the reserve
transfers to note six hundred forty
thousand pounds from the business rates
retain business rates equalization
reserve the new well-being reserve using
the CCG funding I mentioned earlier one
hundred and thirty one thousand pounds
to the planning reserve for legal costs
and ninety four thousand pounds to the
homelessness and temporary accommodation
reserves there are also carried forward
requests totaling one hundred and fifty
three thousand pounds as shown in
paragraph five point sixteen the current
transformation fund projects are listed
in Appendix C with those still open
identified in red in the variance column
you will be pleased to see in Section
five point thirteen that we've been able
to add three hundred fifty five thousand
pounds to the transformation fund and
after accounting for its outstanding
commitments it now stands at seven
hundred and nineteen thousand pounds
moving on to the capital program you'll
see that there is a hundred and forty
thousand pound favorable variance within
the capital program the barker that's
been due to community development grants
the capital program has set out an
appendix e and summarized in paragraph
five point nineteen the main contractual
commitments are shown in paragraph five
point twenty and the carry forward
requests to turn in 5.21 the latter
either plans or aspirations for
investment it is proposed that these
capital resources are carried forward
into twenty twenty to twenty one and
reviewed as part of the corporate plan
to assess whether the original
requirements still exists how it
contributes the strategic priorities so
that we can decide whether the resource
can be redirected or removed I know that
this still includes four million pounds
for Bellevue but the termination of the
hotel project notwithstanding we will
still be looking at this site and the
revised master plan for summary and it
is therefore sensible to carry forward
this route to carry this forward for any
new future project
so moving on to the recommendations I
propose the recommendations at paragraph
3.1 of the report and 3.1 paragraph 3 of
the report 3.1 at the 2019 to 20 to 24
hour turnaround this report be noted at
3.2 that the net transfers at 219
thousand pounds be approved and the
details are provided in paragraph 3.2
3.3 that the general fund carry forward
requests 1350 three thousand pounds are
approved and three point four that the
capital carry forward requests also are
approved as listed in three point four
so I'm proposing that may I have a
seconder please okay hello council Davis
you say okay I'm happy to second thank
you okay thank you very much counselor
are there any questions from anyone no
questions from any member does anyone
wish to make any comment about the
general fund out turn in which case are
we all happy to move to the vote then I
think we'll take it we'll take a vote on
this thank you okay thank you Chad um if
I when I call your name if you could
reply with for against or abstain
councillor our fee for councillor Busby
before we all voted I also had a
question I think of me I haven't seen
anything in the apology story councillor
McCraw yes your name was low my screen I
do apologize the system is not as
responsive as it might be council
general just a point that there are two
versions of the report circulating at
the moment showing slightly different
figures under the second recommendation
and I believe one is an amended updated
version yes that wasn't very clearly
abled in the course of the papers so if
you look on modern gov you will see both
papers are shown amongst the list of
documents available
I found that confusing I hope nobody
else did
right yet just to be clear the amended
one shows that the the correct one the
amended one shows the net transfers at
two hundred and nineteen thousand pounds
and that includes six hundred and forty
thousand transferred from the business
rates equalization Reserve and 355,000
to the transformation fund those are the
correct numbers yeah the ones in the
with the yellow highlighting that's
correct would be the correct ones what
I'm saying is that the other ones are
still in general circulation okay and
are shown on modern gov and that is
confusing potentially and any member of
the public looking at these figures may
have have the out-of-date ones is all
I'm saying
we will make sure that only one version
is is presented to the public then thank
you I'm still prepared to second because
I was using the updated version I'm
happy with that
Thank You castle Davis right we'll move
to the voting Claire okay Thank You
chair look we'll start again from the
beginning
counselor Clyde our fee yeah just to say
that I was aware of the updated report
that's the one that I was looking at and
my my vote is for Thank You councillor
Busby it won't come as any surprise to
know that I was looking at the old one
but there's still four councillor Davis
Oh counselor Holt I can't confirm I was
looking at the updated one and for
councillor mal VC sorry Council you're
on mute for Thank You councillor Osborne
and yeah I can confirm I was also
looking at the updated one and I am for
councillor Parker for
and council award for that's unanimous
Thank You chair Thank You Claire the
next item is paper BCA 1954 the HRA
financial at CERN for 2019 to 2020 I'm
please report to present report BCA 1954
the 2019 to 2020 outturn for the housing
revenue account and capital program the
state the strategic context of the HRA
is set out in paragraphs 4.1 to 4.8 we
have continued to take decisions in line
with a 30-year business plan which have
resulted in positions both revenue and
capital for 2019 to 2020 we are
continuing with our aspiration to
increase our housing stock and now had
three thousand four hundred and forty
three homes 2019 to twenty is the last
year in which we've had to apply the
annual one-percent rent reduction
imposed by the welfare reform and work
act 2016 the impact of code 19 on 2019
to 2020 budget was minimal but it will
be far more significant in terms of both
additional costs and loss of income in
the current year as with the general
funds significant actions may need to be
taken to ensure financial sustainability
in the long term depending on the level
of government support we get again as
with the general fund the impact of
kovin 19 will be monitored and reported
as part of the budget monitoring reports
to cabinet during 20 22 22 on
identifying any in your actions that may
be required and this will also form a
significant part of the considerations
for the budget for the 2021 to 22 year
and the updated medium-term financial
strategy the HRA business ban will be
reviewed this summer to develop a
revised plan in response to the
financial impact of code 19 and
long-term efficience of the housing
service we are confident that the
excellent reserves we have will allow us
to achieve a balanced position for 20 20
to 21 and police report we have a
surplus of one point five or six million
for 2019 to 2020 against the forecast
budget deficit of 193 thousand pounds
that means a net favorable vote variance
of one point six nine nine million
pounds for the year this significant
change is primarily as a result of a
greatly reduced revenue contribution to
capital which I will address in a minute
or two
the key variations on expenditure an
income compared to the budget have been
identified and are presented in
paragraphs five point five two and five
point six the key adverse items are an
income shortfall of one hundred and
twenty-six thousand pounds which mostly
dwelling rains due to timing differences
between actual and planned completion of
new build units three hundred and twelve
thousand pounds for housing management
an increase of six hundred two thousand
pounds for repairs and maintenance as
with last year this is mainly due to the
use of subcontractors to complete
responsive repairs void works and
installation works and there's also been
an increase of one hundred sixteen
thousand pounds from property services
set against these are favorable
variances most notably a lower than
anticipated interest charged on loans
which has resulted in a favorable
variance of two hundred ninety one
thousand pounds and as I mention earlier
the reduction in revenue contribution to
capital of two point five five 1 million
pounds
and this is due to capital underspend
and which is resulted in a reduced
financing requirement the major repairs
Reserve has also been called upon first
of all meaning that the revenue
contribution required is significantly
less than budget the hr8 balance the end
of March is now fourteen point four four
six million pounds as shown in paragraph
five point seven paragraphs five point
eight to five eighteen detailer position
for the HR a capital program with
Appendix A showing the actually capital
expenditure contractual commitments and
carry forwards the table in paragraph
five point 10 provides a summary of the
capital program it shows a favorable
variance of four hundred three thousand
pounds against the budget for twenty
nine point four three six million
reasons for this are given a paragraphs
5.11 is less planned masons carried out
and also none to spend on i.t projects
angel capital expenditure was eleven
point six nine three million pounds the
paragraphs 5.12 and five point thirteen
present the contractual commitments
amounting to eight point one five nine
million and a carry forwards of nine
point one eight one million I should
caution that as explained in paragraph
five point nine it is difficult to
assess the level of payments that were
made during a particular financial year
for complex capital schemes members
should therefore focus on
the overall outcomes are being achieved
and as a result of the capital
investment rather than variances against
the plan for any particular year finally
the HRA earmarked reserves are shown in
Appendix B the budget surplus of one
point five or six million pounds has
been transferred to the strategic
priorities to reserve the total reserves
in our fourteen point four four six
million pounds so I proposed the
recommendations of paragraph 3 of the
report 3.1 at the 2019 to 2020 financial
hour Turner set out and this report be
noted that the transfer of one point
five or six million pounds being a
surplus for the year is transferred to
the strategic priorities Reserve and let
that be approved and that also the
capital forward requests referred to in
5.12 and five point thirteen are also
approved so may I have a seconder please
councillor Osborn thank you I'm happy to
second it does anyone have any questions
about the HRA I'll turn you know okay
top of page 41 it says asbestos surveys
the increased need for surveys is
resulted in an adverse variance of
72,000 I can't believe that we're not at
this point we're not aware of all the
asbestos in our buildings I mean it's
requirement to know that it's been
around for donkey's years how come are
we still suspending money finding these
things out I think that I'll ask Gavin
if he can provide an update on on that
but asbestos is one of those things it's
it's not always possible to know exactly
where it is until you come to come to do
work on on properties but Gavin wood do
you have a and ask for counsel of us B
please
- if if Gavin's not able to speak for
whatever can I suggest something yes and
Dave you're absolutely right we probably
do know an awful lot um however I've got
some properties in shortly that have
recently been or that they're going
through a process and now have been
rebuilt so and they were they were
prefabs built just after the war which
have we know a lot of asbestos in it so
I would I would suggest and I don't know
definitively Kevin I think is on now
that those sort of properties are the
type of things that will be causing us
to have to get asbestos reports thanks
guys
Gavin good morning cabinet and apologies
for the technical issues what I can say
in relation to asbestos surveys is that
we've always had a robust robust
schedule of inspecting and carrying
asbestos removal works and actually when
you grade asbestos you get three levels
low medium and high
and actually we've eradicated all of the
high and amatuer of the medium asbestos
in our homes and we do I think it's fair
to say take a risk adverse approach to
asbestos I think that's rightly so
because we all recognize the importance
of getting it right and as such we do
carry out quite extensive surveys as and
when properties become void and that
those properties may or may not have had
surveys in the past we are taking a
pragmatic view going forward we are
reducing our overall spend on our
external contractors that we use and
members will be aware that towards the
end of 2019 the housing service carried
out a full review and restructure of its
service and as such we appointed made
the decision and appointed an additional
asbestos surveyor so that additional
surveyor will now provide us with the
opportunity to carry out far more survey
work in
rather than relying on external
contractors and then I therefore expect
you to see a reduction in the overall
cost to asbestos and asbestos management
going forward
Thanks going Thank You Gavin castle
Parker Thank You chair and I appreciate
in your presentation you said that it's
it's a complex beast and I accept that
but nonetheless in paragraph 5.6 we're
showing an adverse variance in respect
of receipts that were expected from
development hasn't come forward so I can
I assume then that by definition we can
expect at some point in the future of
favorable variance I mean do we know
when when these new build completions
will occur has it slowed down because of
Kove it was also what's the reason for
that do we know Gavin would you like to
provide castle Parker with detail
responsive there has been a slowdown
obviously with its covert but yes sir
Gavin
going are you able to provide yeah
yes sorry counselor would apologies
there seems to be a problem with the the
mute facility this morning it responds
very slowly unfortunately yeah just in
response I think it's recognized that
what the a dreary business plan attempts
to do is accurately predict income
expenditure to any given in a given
month and therefore what has
traditionally happened in the past based
on the explanations or assumptions being
made by the affordable housing team
developing and acquiring new housing
they're built into the the business plan
to a particular month clearly there are
always ongoing challenges with the
development of new housing and it's not
just covert related that may cause a
delay and therefore as part of the HRA
review this year in terms of the
business plan we will reviewing how we
record and accurately predict future
income from new build housing what
you're seeing is the the lag of housing
coming forward and thus thus being able
to to charge a a rent and obviously at
100 pounds per week per property you can
see why that would build up quite
significantly quite quickly so I
acknowledge that what we needed to do is
be able to accurately predict that and
and therefore work will take place as
the business plan review to do that I
think in terms of Co vid we've we've not
seen any immediate impacts what we
actually have seen I know from a couple
of schemes that I've been sitting on the
periphery of is actually developed as
wanting to expediate that the
transactions and actually want us to
move from exchange to complete in less
than four weeks which isn't something
that we've historically done on honor on
a particular scheme more recently so I'm
not sure that the effects have been seen
as as yet but obviously we continue to
work with developers that we may be
acquiring through section 106 or may be
bidding for housing to understand their
situation
thanks Aaron council halt yeah question
for Gavin really the biggest adverse
variance is six hundred and thirteen
thousand for Responsive repairs and
maintenance King just give us some
background as to how come that's got to
that figure and what were the benefits
to to us as a council for spending that
excess amount of money yes certainly
council Hall and thank you for the
question in relation to building
services I was hoping someone was going
to ask the question because actually
I've developed a response which I think
members will be will be happy with when
when they understand that the bigger
picture so firstly there's no excuse for
the level of variances between q3 and q4
and I would summarize that that between
September last year and January this
year a significant restructure of the
team took place and that result within
nearly a quarter of the housing service
including officers being at risk
inevitably this has taken some time just
to to effect as roles and
responsibilities change in relation to
building service more specifically yes
there is a significant additional
expenditure and we've seen that in
relation to subcontractors if I take
members back to the heady days before
covert 19 and if you looked back at
April 19 we were obviously spending
significant amounts on void contractors
to carry out major works and that was
the in result of decision making to
reduce void times to it to an acceptable
level if you were to look at current
performance reports you will see that
void performance is actually now well
below the target of 21 days and on
average is averaging around 14 to 15
days if I take you forward from April 19
for out last year we saw a reduction in
the amount of reliance on subcontractors
to deliver voids as the building
services team equipped itself to take
that work and deliver that work
on an ongoing basis yes they will
naturally be a need for subcontractors
from time to time but in relation to
voids there's been less reliance if I
catapult you to April this year and that
at the beginning of lockdown you could
assume that actually that would have a
significant impact on the building
services team actually across Baber
and mid Suffolk the team delivered and
returned 60 empty properties during
lockdown where most obviously colleagues
were working from home and I think
that's testament to the team and gives
you a sense as the direction of travel
that that team using safe systems work
and clearly having to operate in a very
different way we're able to return that
number of voids to to back to the
council for for letting what we have
recognized in relation to subcontractor
spend is we do rely on a number of
subcontractors for a very specialist
work and in an example of that would be
perhaps windows and doors and therefore
over the last 12 months we've developed
a training schedule for all staff in the
service which identifies the opportunity
to provide additional training in
relation to specialist roles and
therefore really reduce our reliance on
subcontractors in addition to that we
have identified that some some
subcontractors are being used for large
amounts of reactive work and when I talk
about reactive work I'd referred to for
example fencing repairs a fencing
improvements and members will be aware
of the dramatic effects of a storm
earlier this year in January which
exacerbated that problem as such what
we've done as a result is we're
developing capital programs of activity
where we can let a contract for that
activity and develop some economies of
scale based on on the volume of work
being offered and in the latter half of
last year beginning of this year we've
also been reviewing our contracts and
identifying savings where possible and
examples of that have been delivered
through a whole have services and
contract as well as our material
supplier
Bergman's Thank You Gavin does anyone
else have a question on the castle
McCraw I just wondered from Gavin since
he's on at the moment
there was discussion prior to the
shutdown that there would be further
forthcoming changes in the model we're
using for Responsive repairs I'd just
like to ask if that's still under
consideration or whether it's been put
to one side until we deal with kovat 19
effects Thank You councillor McCraw in
answer to your question I intend to
bring back to a cabinet briefing next
Monday in effect a conversation with the
cabinet and present where we are in in
terms of our transformation of building
services and that will include decision
making going forward about the delivery
of that service I think what I can in in
effect make you aware of a council
McCraw is that during lockdown
both Weber and mid Suffolk and flagship
housing have made the decision to not
proceed with the development of a
business case around a joint venture and
as such the conversation with the
cabinet next week
will be around what next in relation to
that service and how we take that
service forward investing in it to in
further enhance and improve the delivery
of that service I think it's important
to recognize that year-on-year
over the last three years the actual
overall deficit for building services
has and is reducing and thus improving
and since January more than 6,000
outstanding job tickets have been closed
which date back to 2017 thus leaving
Building Services now with a normal
level of of work-in-progress
thank you that's very helpful Thanks
going councillor hold
yeah just following up Gavin what you
said I mean I think it's we all realize
we have a problem with voids and I think
the work done to reduce that has been
actually fantastic and also to hear of
the 60 empty houses that were that were
brought back in during the code
situation going forward
are we happy now that we can budget far
better for this expenditure and that we
want or shouldn't see such an adverse
variance in the coming years
yes thank you
council halt yes I believe that
particularly the delivery of the
outstanding jobs will allow us to to
budget and predict our budget in in a
far more intuitive way which I would
expect you not to see the level of
adverse variances it is always difficult
particularly with the delivery of
building services for example we may see
a significant increase in the cost of
materials as we have done with with
certain materials since as a result of
kovat but we are doing everything we
possibly can to minimize cost and
increase income and I hope the
presentation I bring to you next Monday
in a cabinet briefing or summer
summarize the interventions that have
taken place and the progress that we
want to make in terms of our plans going
forward which will give you more
reassurance uncertainty around budgets
thanks Gavin that's great right if there
are no further questions then we'll move
to the vote for this you've had the
recommendations proposed and seconded
there can we take a vote please okay
again when I call your names for against
Austin Council our fee Oh
councillor Busby Davis walk councillor
Holt poor council ml VC for councillor
Osborne for councillor Parker for and
councillor Ward for that's unanimous
chair Thank You Claire okay then moving
on to the next item on the agenda I have
got my hand up actually oh you just put
it up there I indeed yeah it was really
just to give you full credit
for your reports and presentations this
morning it's no criticism of your
predecessors but I have to say that you
do have an impressively complete
understanding of our budgets and our
apps and figures so thank you very much
and well done Thank You Kathy made my
day thank you I wrote every word of
those reports myself right moving on
where are we yeah
okay the next item is paper BCA 1955 the
adoption of the revised table affairs
for Hackney carriages and I'd like to
ask councillor Mulvey C to introduce
this paper please Thank You mr. chairman
some background information local
authority set the maximum rate of the
fares for Hackney carriages in their
district and the last time we did it in
Baber was in 2016 and no doubt everyone
will agree that a lots happened since
then the local authority has no power to
set fares for private hire where the
vehicle must be pre booked and the rate
is set by the operator solely taxi
meters and the corresponding fare table
are calibrated in imperial units
although metric equivalents can also be
shown the calculation of these tariffs
is complex and allows for both for being
both stationary and moving so the tariff
comprises the flag fare which is when
you put your hand up and stop them on
the road waiting time the drop time and
running time and they're all interlinked
increase one and it knocks the others
out which then makes it difficult to
work in the meter the aim is to achieve
a reasonable income for the operator
taking into account all the costs of
maintaining a vehicle to today's
standards but it is the operators
decision whether they charge the maximum
fare or not however the meter must show
the maximum fare allow
consultations started on the 5th of
March with statutory notices being
published in the East Anglia Daily Times
at the cancer offices as well as a
customer access points within the
district and this is a requirement under
Section 65 of the local government
miscellaneous provisions Act 1976 part 2
there were no responses from the public
and only 12 from the trade who strangely
enough objected to the tariffs and their
comments are recorded in Appendix C with
the officers comments in appendix D the
current tariff sets a date-time rate and
a nighttime rate but at the moment on
bank holidays they charge either 50
percent or a hundred percent to the
daytime rate you think that simple well
no it's not because some people apply it
to the final fare and some people apply
it to the flag fare so there's no
consistency because it's a percentage
that's being applied and if it's fifty
or a hundred percent of the total fare
because the two will not arrive at the
same figure and I can tell you that I've
experienced it I've arrived back at
Sudbury railway station on a bank
holiday and my fee with one car with one
taxi company was X and then two weeks
later when they're not two weeks later a
lot later with another bank holiday it
was a different fare now why do I
remember because I was working and it
was expenses so I had to record it so
this is a problem for the fair payer who
ends up doing the exact same trip of
being charged different rates
consequently the primary aim of the
review was to remove percentages as part
of the equation from the beba tariff
table because it's now considered poor
practice and it is this historical use
of percentages which resulted in the
objections because different operators
applied it differently and they saw the
new proposal as a reduction in their
wages which it is not
officers considered each objection and
as a consequence presented the licensing
committee with four alternative
proposals on the 12th of June and after
much deliberation the committee decided
to recommend proposal 4 which is the one
before you now personally speaking I
believe that it was the complexity of
the calculations along with perhaps too
many proposals that resulted in a narrow
majority with some members of the
committee abstaining because they did
not fully comprehend the complex nature
of what had been presented but I very
much hope that I have simplified the
rationale for cabinet today and that
therefore I am able to propose that you
accept the revised table Affairs to
become effective 27th of July 2020 but
also to be aware that the policies of
Hackney carriages and private hire for
Baber and mid Suffolk are currently
under review and will come before the
licensing and regulatory committee in
October this year the intention is that
the new policy will require an annual
review of tariffs to ensure that they
remain in line with consumer price index
in the future although there will be a
joint policy for Baber
and mid Suffolk the tariff tables are
unlikely to be completely harmonized due
to the nature of the districts the most
common journey types differ greatly in
and around Sudbury they tend to be urban
and short
whereas in mid Suffolk they tend to be
rural and longer and before I finish I
would like to say thank you to the team
who number crunched and worked very
diligently in pulling together what is a
very complex scenario thank you thank
you Katherine well VC so you're
proposing the the paper may have a
seconder please well I will be happy to
second that human are there any
questions from anyone
catarah fee yeah my question is probably
a bit of a basic one but it's similar to
the question that I think so Karpin dial
asked at licensing and it's reading the
updated Appendix II the thing that I
find a little bit difficult to
understand is why we have to have
variable amounts and distances why can't
the amounts remain constant and the
distances change or the amounts change
and the distances remain constant if you
look from tariff 1 2 to 3 the the the
subsequent distances are the same amount
for different distances which you expect
because they're different tariffs but
the the normal rights for some reason
the amount and the distance has to
change with each and I'm not quite sure
why that's the case it seems to be
overly complicated
I will ask Emma rich Bell to respond to
that please counselor I think I can give
you a very simple answer to that
unfortunately it's about making a
workable tariff that works in the meter
it is difficult in that if you change
one part of the tariff it changes
another and so you have to almost play
with we have a spreadsheet that we put
these figures into to ensure that the
various elements of the tariff give a
consistent running mile for example so
that each mile after the first one which
was always more expensive because that
includes your flag fare after that you
want each extra mile that the passenger
travels to cost the same so you don't
end up with an exponential increase for
a long journey for example and you
achieve that by that really quite fiddly
adjust
of both yardage and cost so yes I agree
with you it does look very complicated
but what it hopefully gives is a tariff
that to the person which she pays the
fare at the end is sensible and emma is
it true to say that the net result of
that between the terrace one two and
three is that you will get the overall
fifty percent an overall 100 percent
increase on the whole fare rather than
just variable increases on on components
of the fare I wouldn't like to say that
it's exactly it is fifty plan or a
hundred percent but what it achieves is
a sensibly increased cost for your night
time and your bank holiday charges so
yeah I mean the difficulty were trying
to compare this is where a lot of
problem has come in trying to compare
what the drivers will be getting with
what they were getting was because if
the tariffs were being applied in very
different ways by different operators so
we almost can't say that's what they
were charging and this is how it
compares because it's very difficult to
know there has been clearly very
different interpretation from different
operators we understand now from
discussion with one Operator that he was
actually choosing to charge the the
night rate for larger vehicles which is
completely as actually an offence but
that's a reason from that confusion on
how those percentages are to be applied
so it's a key element of what we tried
to do is is to remove that confusion but
I take the potential out which on the
face of it is you read the tariffs seem
simple but actually they've caused very
very many problems and a lot of
variation as councillor Maori see
explained it in in actually what you pay
as a customer thanks Emma councillor
Davis
thank you yeah I understand from Liz's
very good summary at the beginning that
there's going to be a whole review of
the licensing within Bieber in October
so given that the complex nature of this
and the clear lack of understanding by
many people many parties while we
pushing this through now why can't the
the licensing fairs be part of the the
bigger review so then it all marries
together and everybody will hopefully
will have a better understanding in
October we'll be reviewing the policy of
both MIT Suffolk and Weber whereas now
we're looking at the tariffs for Bieber
and try and this is an attempt to align
and tidy up so that when we discuss and
review the policies it doesn't become
bogged down and clouded because this is
such a complex issue on its own it's
better to be dealt with separately Thank
You castle Avicii because the Davis you
okay with that response well yeah I
understand with you but I understand
what you're saying yeah I just think
clearly from the all the correspondence
that we've had that this isn't and
everyone's admitted it's a complex issue
and I just think it's worthy of further
discussion and actually working out what
is the best for the operators and for
the customers and I notice that there
were no responses from the public it's
probably because they don't understand
it either and I just think it needs to
be a lot lot clearer and a lot better so
people know what they're getting here in
Baber you know and I don't particularly
by the fact that Sudbury is different
stone market in terms of you know it's
urban and then rural because Babers a
very rural area as well and if it
happens to be getting off the train at
Sudbury and and you live
I don't know tapas
it's just as rural surely that wasn't a
question it was rhetorical yeah I
gathered cats the holes yeah thank you I
think this just highlights that the
original committee the presentation and
the papers that were presented to the
members we've had admitted in that there
were some issues with the papers and
it's clear from listening to the
committee that there are at least four
members who admitted that it was far too
complex for them and there even would
have rested further training to actually
understand what they were meant to be
passing passing in front of them to me
this should go back to committee it
should be made a lot clearer yes there
was a consultation with the operators
there was letter sent in 12 I think was
the number quoted but we've had a
further 10 companies since that sending
emails whether it be under one email law
or separate emails who just can't and
don't agree with what is proposed at the
end of the day these are the operators
these are the people who are in business
to provide us with the taxi service and
our residence for the service that we
all need and we all use occasionally the
bottom line is if those operators don't
feel then the drivers don't feel that
there is a living to be made out of this
we will lose it will lose the
availability of taxis at night will lose
the availability of taxes after midnight
bank holidays and it's going to hit us
all it will hit our residents it will
hit our economy which is very important
to me and I just think that that this
paper it needs to be rethought it needs
to go back it needs further consultation
we need to try and get agreement with
the operators of a system that is
implemented whether it's a lack of
explanation from our point of view to
the operators of how it's meant to work
the input the how it's meant to be
implemented the meters use whether they
can be adjusted whether I don't know but
to me there is not enough common ground
for both parties to proceed with this it
to be clear to the operators what they
are going to be meant to be implementing
yes the ones I've spoken to and I spoke
to three separate companies they're not
I mean live in the real world that
they're not looking for huge increases
it's not about that the main concern for
the operators have been for their
customers how they are going to price
and how they are going to charge their
customers the second thing was their
drivers not profit drivers so it's
customers first drivers second how are
they going to retain the drivers the
drivers themselves have looked at this
it is complicated I don't think any of
us really get it but it's complicated
and those drivers are already talking
about it isn't going to be worth their
while doing the job you have no drivers
in the evening you have no drivers at
night you have no drivers at bank
holidays we have no cabs so the bottoms
the third thing was yes they would like
an increase their costs have gone up
over the the four years since it was
really last done so if they're not being
driven by profit they're not being
driven by greed they're being driven by
a system that the moment is been put in
front of them is far too complex either
as I say they need it needs explain it
to them but we need to get a meeting
with them we need to get this thrashed
out have an agreement on a way forward
as I say it's not about profit not from
the companies I spoke to and we need to
get this sorted so that everyone's happy
when we get the service that we want and
our residents need can I respond yes you
say it's not about profit but they've
said that they're not going to meet the
money on bank holidays and Christmas so
they're not prepared to drive therefore
that's profit and that would indicate
greed and I don't know I'm sorry but
cancel my basic please continue yeah the
extra ten we've received I don't know
whether they are extra to the 12 that
there is that responded or whether they
are overlap with those that originally
responded
but I do hear what you're saying it is
complex it's something that I've come
across before not for taxi carriage
tariffs but for queueing theory how
retailers work out exactly how many
tills they're going to have in a given
store but I do think some of the
language is a little bit emotive and I
don't think that serves anybody's
purpose I I do hear what you're saying
and what others have said but perhaps we
need to get round the table and actually
work through it
I presume the meters are they're
designed by somebody else and they're
set to take a running mile a drop a
waiting time a flag fare and it's those
components that combination of those
elements that produce the subtotal that
seems to be causing problem
Thank You councillor caster Parker yeah
Thank You chair I concur wholeheartedly
actually with councillor Holt on this
one and I will just say chair we're used
to receiving any amount of
representation around things
particularly for example around you know
say for the planning function for
example we've received a good deal of
representation from operators over the
last few weeks about this and seldom do
you see representation that is so
consistent and it is the operators it's
the experts that are telling us that
this is is the most complicated of
tariffs that you know that are being
introduced here so I've no doubt that
the the intention here is all with with
good intentions as I'm sure that is the
case but it's not clear and if it's if
it's not transparent then it's not fair
and so for that reason alone I mean I
think
the conversation that we're having here
shows that we ourselves struggling to
understand the complexity of this so
therefore on a technical basis alone I
can't support this paper as it stands
I'm afraid and we're going to need it
and we're going to need to come back and
we're gonna need to listen a little bit
more to the operators and so that's my
comments chair thank you Thank You
councillor Aarthi is your hand slap from
last time or no no it's up again I
haven't finished last time okay but a
couple more things have cropped up in
the in the discussion the first one I
think somebody mentioned something about
how we haven't heard anything from
passengers well I don't think we would
have done really I mean most of us when
we use a taxi we get in we watch the
meter and when we get out we pay I
suspect that if anybody has a question
about the tariffs and the fares it's the
driver that has to answer the question
you know very few people would get out
of a taxi and then contact the local
authority to get some explanation of
their fare so it does have to be
understood I think by the drivers and it
should be as as clear as possible
another question that arose out of what
councillor Parker was saying is about
consistency really so do we know what
other districts are doing I read one of
the supporting well excited I think it
was a supporting paper it was something
sent through by one of the respondents I
think Fox cabs or something which was
about how this is a sort of an in the
intention is to get some sort of cross
boundary agreement I think not
necessarily national but the intention
is to get some consistency so I just
wondered if we knew what other districts
were doing and finally it's a question
about what the operators have to do as a
result of the change because of course
they're meters either I guess have to be
reprogrammed or something
do they have to have new meters and it
seems from some of the correspondence
that we've had that the meter companies
have to accommodate all manner of
tariffs being charged all over the
country so that really goes back to my
question resulting from councillor
Parker's comments and that is about
consistency you know it are are we
coming in line with a sort of a
recognised way of doing things
or are we just going it alone and all
the other districts going to do the same
and it will be just as mixed up as it
was before
thanks Kathy part of it okay then it
does bring us in line with them with
most of the other councils thank you and
the other thing is that yes the meters
have to be recalibrated emerald David
can you provide some more detail on that
because it touches on one of the
questions I've got and that is how easy
would it be to recalibrate the meters
for the three different tariffs that
we've got in Appendix II it's a
straightforward matter for the meter
agents to program in the tariff that's
provided to them and actually it's a
much more straightforward matter to
program with the tariff that we're
presenting here than to use one with
percentages which then has to be
interpreted right thank you
Karthi has the responses from casa loma
vc you never covered most of what you
you asked about or is there anything
you've still got outstanding on from
that yeah I think they have I'd I would
just like some sort of confirmation
about the other district so they going
through the same thing at the same time
as us because I'm guessing that there
are operators who don't follow district
boundaries so I'm guessing that there
are some operators that operate in more
than one district so it would be quite
useful to know that
consistency across districts where are
you able to yeah I might ask David to
respond that shot that one but I believe
it is it's a local issue for local
authority to set their own tariffs and
Hackney driver is is bound by the tariff
set by his district regardless of where
he trades but David might bear to expand
a little on that thanks Emma
thank you Jeff I'm going to keep my
camera off if I may and play audio
because my my computer is acting up
today again we obviously have a look at
each individual Council the rest of the
stuff that we look at when we're
calculating our fares I've had a chat
with other councils obviously Ipswich
did theirs last year is Suffolk are
looking to do their so obviously it's
might not be imminent but that probably
and if not this year will be next year
and West have already looked at theirs
in previous years
we're behind are you know can I just say
that doesn't quite answer the question I
wasn't asking when they did it I was
asking what they did
oh well in terms of having a tariff
structure similar to the one we're
proposing in order to iron out some of
the previous anomalies over percentages
yeah quite that's a good good question
yeah David are you able to pick up on
that yes yeah I am and the only council
that has percentages within it is East
and that is I believe the self district
has a percentage within its toe tariff
table nobody else has entities within
their tariff table so they all have
separate tariffs for to cover nighttime
and bank holidays yes they do
thank you councils born yeah Thank You
mr. chairman and thank you council my VC
for your introduction it didn't shine a
little bit of light on it
I actually concur with councillor Holton
councillor Parker and being asked to
make a decision on us on a subject that
I really am finding very very complex
and I would much rather I was much
better informed before I voted this
through I would rather it be put on hold
for the time being and be deferred and
come back to us when I for one have a
much better understanding of what I'm
actually voting through this is a very
important subject it needs us to
understand that subject before we can
actually take a vote either approve or
to refuse Thank You mr. chairman Thank
You councillor before I go on to capsule
McRoy I just got one quick question
myself if I may and that's concerning
the the hourly waiting time charge which
apparently is the result of the the new
tariff is going to reduce from 15 pounds
to 210 pounds 90 per hour okay either
emerald David can you confirm that
that's the case and if so why and what
what else is in in the the proposed
tariffs to offset against that David did
you want to respond to that one are my
understanding is at the way to time
overall is increased but could you
explain that one for the happen at
please yes Jeff and in terms of each
it's particularly tariffs the running
mile will increase by in the proposed
alternative to the one that went out to
consultation there's a proposed increase
in running mile which is the subsequent
mile there after the initial mile of
20px to so it's a 180 running miles 160
an 18-pound waiting time in tariff one
instead of a 15 or in terms of what went
out 11 pound in tariff in tariff to the
night right hmm there is an increase in
running mile of another 20 P again
- 2 pounds 60 and an Inc a much bigger
increase to 24 pounds from 20 to 50 20
to 50 and what is being charged out
there and have three there is another 20
P increase on on the running mile - 3
pound for teens to the 3 pound 20 and as
a bigger jump of 6 pound on the waiting
charge in ter 3 instead of 30 pounds so
why is it some of the operators are
suggesting that their hourly waiting
time is is reducing significantly and
they've calculated that we've been ten
pound 90 per hour rather than the
current 15 how did they miss
miscalculated that or arm can you
explain why they believe that's the case
can I answer that yeah yes that was in
the original proposed turf that went out
to consultation officers found an error
within the inner tariff and recalculated
it whereby then dropped to 11 pounds per
hour instead of 15 pounds that went out
to consultation we took on board all
trades responses and came up with some
work proposals in those work proposals
for was perceived to be the best because
it gave a lot more to the trade it gave
an increase on their running mile it
gave or an increase on the waiting time
so they were actually getting more now
than what they were getting before right
okay so those responses from the trade
are based on all old figures and not the
latest Appendix II yes - Thank You
councillor McGraw's next on the list
I'd suggest I defer to cabinet members
first chair if that's all right with you
yeah
happy with that yes yeah Castle Busbee
thanks just to confirm that I'm looking
at the right thing is it the the tariff
one is 320 for the first five hundred
and eighty five yards and then tariff
two is 460 for the first five hundred
and forty four he loves that the revised
Appendix II that was attached separately
in in the modern gov and it was sent out
as a separate email yes just not labeled
as Appendix II anyway I mean that just
seems crazy I think I agree with the the
deferral is to look at it to have three
separate lengths why don't we just have
a fixed charge to start with four quid
for the first one 5 quid for the second
whatever it is and if they want to go
one yard then they still pay the four
grid plus whatever the additional
yardage is I mean and this seems crazy
and then to go to all that trouble of
saying it's 20 P per additional
passenger in excess of - are we really
getting down to that kind of level where
we Chardon worrying about 20 P if so
again I think that should be built into
the into the charity I would have
thought well I don't use taxis very
often but my habits is it 10 quid 11
quid 12 quid is not is it 12 pounds 45
an outcome you've got the extra 45 P you
don't kind of worried about the pendency
so much it's a bit yes
what kind of pound figure and then we've
got this in the extra charges how can
you explain this sixty P each additional
passenger in excess of the first two
additional passengers incurring twenty
to twenty P above in vehicles license to
carry more than four passengers only
blimey well I mean you could have a
degree in math to work some of these
things out why we still thinking in
yards was it kind of tenths of miles
it's
Oh points taken castle buzzer it is
common practice to charge for extra
passengers separately like that so that
that's not something that that's unusual
and you find that everywhere I think
some taxi firms do and some don't so it
is it is down to the operator just
choose but it's in it's in imperial
measurements because of some Act of
Parliament which escapes me yeah we
choose to do things on our roads in
yards miles feet and inches but we buy
clothes in centimeters marks inspectors
did go back to the original committee
and the papers presented to to the
members of that committee I think there
was errors would be all admit there was
errors in there the papers they were
looking at had errors I don't see how we
can expect to approve a paper that was
passed by them when we all admit and
that there were errors in that paper if
that wasn't correct he should go back to
that committee for them to look at
properly put together a document but
before that I stress that I would
seriously consider having a forum with
with the taxi operators to ensure that
whatever is put together is something
that they're happy to operate with I'm
not sadly have to do what they want by
no means but we need to take their
opinions on board you might say we have
done but with what we've been presented
I don't think it really reflects what
what what the concerns were if anything
it's unearthed more problems going
forward so I would certainly defer this
and I would ask that we engage with the
operators so that we can come to a
mutual agreement and put that back to
the committee and then come back to
cabinet because just that conversation
chair that you
have with with the officer again that
just illustrates that you know that that
was similar to the committee meeting
that there was no clear answers that you
have information in front of you were
referring to information that was
incorrect and Appendix II that's just
come out I mean it's not a document that
any of the operators I would imagine
would have seen possibly if that have
been looking at it but I just I just
can't support this I'm sorry Thank You
councillor counsel Busby your hands
still up you have another question no
sorry
okay can I can I ask the assistant
director to comment on it please on our
discussions I think also Emily has got
her hand up as well all right okay thank
you Joe if I might just jump in there
listening to the debate and anticipating
the direction that the cabinet might
want to go in on this this matter you
have a proposal that's been seconded
that you would need to take a vote on to
accept the recommendation in the paper
if that's voted against then ultimately
you're left with a situation of no
change so if the cabinet's desire is to
send this back to the licensing
committee for further consideration
which would be your appropriate route to
have those more detailed complex debates
then actually it would be best for the
current motion to be withdrawn by the
proposer and seconder and for an
alternative motion to be put which would
be to refer the matter back to committee
Thank You Gerry
thanks Emily Cass did you want to say a
few things at this point good morning
cabinet thank you very much for bringing
me into the discussion so I just wanted
to summarize I think Emily's probably
caught the directing pretty well there
and but I did just want to summarize
exactly what would happen for cabinet
say and what a little bit of clarity
about what has happened so where the
trades were thinking that the tariff was
unfair that was absolutely fed back
through the statutory consultation that
was done via the licensing committee
and it was that consultation response
that the team worked on and the tariff
that's before you today as David
indicated each section of that tariff
has been increased based on the
consultation received back and so I can
understand
absolutely everyone's commented that
this is a complex item I completely
agree and if this were to go back to
licensing committee which it seems is
the way you're going it was just to
clarify that this tariff that you are
seeing today is the tariff that officers
were are suggesting to licensing
committee and that the majority did vote
on to come to cabinet so the work that
would go on at licensing committee would
be to make sure that this is completely
transparent and understood by everybody
it wouldn't be a different tariff it
wouldn't be different figures that are
going because everything that's been
shown to you today is in response to the
original consultation
it had the errors removed and I do
apologize that there were errors there
that the errors have been removed so
just to clarify it would be the tariff
that you're looking at today is what we
would go back to licensing committee and
ensure everybody was fully in Vandor
stood of how about how those figures and
all those formulas have been commenting
thank you chair base casts capsule of
Busbee and that's what we want I think
we're saying that the tariff has been
recommended here is overcomplicated we
need somebody to rethink it and come up
with a simple one I think the tap the
way the tariff is arrived at is
determined by the hackney carriage
scheme which is a running mile a drop a
flag fare and yeah those elements and
those elements have to be satisfied and
met and put into the meter I don't think
the complexity of the calculation is one
that we can run away from because it
seems to be determined by the way
Hackney
marriages are set up and and run on a
meter yeah yeah I hear that but we've
got three different terrorists and this
Clive said right at the start you've got
a different amount and a different
amount of yards for each tariff that
isn't necessary you could have a
different amount but for the same yards
same amount I don't think you need to
have different amounts of different
yards it just seems crazy especially
when you're making it 585 yards and 462
yards the distances are irrelevant
proposal is a tariff on the day rate in
other words the proposal in front of
cabinet is what was decided by the
licensing committee which is not a
selection of four different tariffs they
narrowed it down to one tariff and what
I'm asking committee cabinet is to
either decide that we do nothing which I
don't think is the way forward or to
accept the proposal of the licensing
committee what I hear from you is that
you would like to you would like me to
withdraw the proposal and suggest that
we take it back to the licensing
committee so that we can simplify the
terminology and the narrative so that
more people can understand but we can't
change the way the actual meter is set
up would not ask you that as I said but
simplify but we've only got one Tarek
we've only got essentially one tariff so
it's a day rate a nitrate and a bank
holiday rate well that's three tariffs
oh that's what we I'm going to get
Arthur to come in in a minute because
he's put his hand up before I go to
cancel the whole but the councillor
Busby and we do need that we do need to
have the separate
a night and bank holiday rates and the
way that the current terrorists have
been calculated is to remove the
application of percentages and bake
those into those nighttime and bank
holidays so that that principal I think
is a valid principle the question is can
I just come in here mr. chairman the
changes in yardage for the day rate
against the night rate against the bank
holiday rate is because by changing the
amount the distance that you travel is
the way that you increase the tariff to
the benefit of the driver so if you
drive a hundred then your system would
require either the night time rate goes
from twenty pence
to forty pence or fifty pence which is
probably a bit more difficult for the
for that to be calibrated into the
system whereas if you apply it on the
distance traveled you keep the unit cost
the same but you're yeah you're you're
getting to the destination
look I'm not a taxi operator but have
any of the operators come in and said
yeah we like this and and this is where
we as part of that the work that if we
have a revised proposal to devote on
today part part of part of that will be
to ensure that we do go back to the
operators and try to explain with worked
examples how the tariff system that has
been proposed will work to their benefit
and how it could be implemented so there
are there are a number of things that
clearly we've got to do but and and it
may be that we end up with with some a
revised tariff as a result of that those
discussions but that the principle of
trying to erase application percentages
by building though
those increases in two separate terrace
enough for night and bank holidays does
from everything I've heard from car
özdemir VC from Eman from David that
does make sense that we just got to make
sure we get it right Arthur would you
like to say something at this point
Thank You chairman and I'm conscious
that cosmic roar hasn't had a chance to
come in but but I'm also very mindful of
the fact that you're in danger of all
going around the circle's and clearly
you have a licensing committee to do the
majority of this work for you so that
you don't have to have this kind of
debate and all all become licensing
experts and particularly taxing
licensing experts in cabinet Kasim faz
mouth as he said most of what I was
going to say but she stopped just short
and I think the key thing for you
chairman is whatever council mouth Daisy
is withdrawing the report and I believe
you second did it and so whether you're
also withdrawing you're seconding in
which case it will take the path the
Mosuo outlined in terms of going back to
the licensing committee otherwise I
think I would suggest you now proceed to
the vote but I think the mood of the
cabinet appears to be in the other
direction which is to withdraw and allow
time for it to be to be reconsidered
Thank You counsel Holt did you want to
quickly say something before we wrap
this up yes I mean I from where we're
going it's gonna it's gonna be removed
withdrawn but I do stress I think we
need to engage but the operators to
ensure that whatever is put back to the
licensing committee is something that
all parties can work with it was
interesting obviously the licensure
committee would put in front of what was
put in front was of papers drawn up by
officers and I wonder where the steer
came for those officers to actually go
down this route and change it so
drastically I appreciate that other
authorities have been doing this but it
was quite conscious that the East
Suffolk I think it was weren't going
along these lines and the other thing
that hasn't been mentioned is is type of
vehicles whether they're four seater six
seater and the specialist vehicles I
can't really see the charges where the
specialist vehicles coming to either so
I'd like some more clarity on that and
the new paper please thank you guys for
hope right Oh counselor
Arthur your hands gone up again yeah
it's really probably a question for Emma
the proposal was that the new tariffs
would come in at the end of this month
the paper also says that it's been four
years since they were last reviewed so
really the question is does another two
months cause a problem not in that
respect all right I'm sorry I was just
gonna say that what's coming before
committee in October is the taxi policy
which isn't specifically tariffs so this
was an opportunity to give as soon as
possible an increase to the trade which
necessarily will be delayed now will
hope that delay can be as short as
possible thank you can I still come into
a chair
yes cutter a councillor macro of course
and perhaps I should've brought this in
sooner but it refers back to a point
made by councilor RC regarding practice
elsewhere and I've heard mention of
Sudbury of Hadley East Suffolk mid
Suffolk what area I haven't heard
mention of is the fact that on our
southern border many of the residents
will be using taxi firms based in
tendering and perhaps even Colchester
and the practice there might be of
interest I don't know whether that's
being considered or not but I think it
should be all I can say is that over my
years of experience of using Manningtree
cabs or various things and operators
working there one thing I have noticed
this is a difficulty they have in the
retention of drivers and that's under
whatever system they are using drivers
disappear sometimes come back but it's
undoubtedly a really challenging
business to be in and I don't think we
can be doing anything that's going to
get in the way of a provision of any
taxi service it needs to be encouraged
and and supported as far as we can at
the same time supporting the residents I
just wanted to throw that in because I
thought that is actually a significant
portion of usage of taxis route that
revolves around railway stations and man
increased
is rather a critical one in this
instance so that that's just if all I'd
have to say is I think you have a very
difficult task in front of you I think
you're quite right then that the last
thing we want to do is to implement a
system that that's going to result in
many drivers leaving leaving the
business and consequently the lack of
availability of taxis that will not do
any our residents any good whatsoever
right councilor hold your hand is like
you got a something finally you anything
you want to say no right okay cuz I'm a
VC then can I propose then that we
withdraw this paper today and that we
send it back to the licensing committee
but do we at this point have to clarify
what we want the licensing committee to
do yes I think provide some guidance yes
thank you chair so um there are two
parts that you need to do to get a
motion that you want to take forward in
this situation the first is that
councillor mal VZ needs to withdraw the
motion that's on the table that you have
seconded chair and then you will need to
put forward a separate motion that says
you would like to refer the matter back
to the licensing committee and it would
be helpful if you added some context to
that to include your requirements for
some further consultation or some
further engagement might be the more
appropriate word with the trades so at
least you just need to say that the
proposal is that the matter be referred
back to the license and committee at
best if you could also add some context
as to what you would like them to do
with the matter that that would be
beneficial but the first point is to
withdraw the existing motion Thank You
chair thanks Emily
so castle my vc you're formally
withdrawing the motion yes I am and as
your second I I concur with that
so we can withdraw that motion so we no
need a word a replacement motion which
as as Emily said would be to refer to
licensing with further engage I've got
some notes here that it returns to
licensing for further engagement with
the industry and to better understand
the tariff structure when compared with
others in the area yes yeah do we want
to add any any principles that we
understand and accept that the need to
remove the application of percentages as
a separate charging mechanism into to
have a structure that that does build in
percentages all right I think I think we
do because your sensors don't always
give you the answer that you want
exactly but it needs to be something
that is the justification needs to be
supported by empirical evidence on why
they should be removed okay well can we
say something like that in in the
revised proposal then yep are you asking
me or are you asking Emily for
clarification well I was asking you to
just then dump out some words while I
ask councillor Aarthi he's just put his
hand up yeah John me to go now yeah
please
okay well I'm thinking not just about
the operators that operate in our
district but I'm also thinking about the
residents that live in our district and
the taxis they might use so can we
please ask that licensing committee look
at comparisons and particularly or to
include Colchester hips which tendering
and West Suffolk and then of course
there's the question of what mid Suffolk
do so I'm not quite sure how that ties
in a mid Suffolk considering this later
on something
thank you I've got Arthur and Emily who
put their hands up
I think Arthur yours was first thank
chairman and I'll be brief and hopefully
we won't cut across what Emily watches
to say but all I was gonna say is I
would recommend you keeping your new
recommendation as simple and as short as
possible the detail that you are getting
into would arguably be tying the hands
of the licensing committee as I said
earlier they're there to do the role for
you in that respect but in any event the
detail of this debate which of course is
all recorded and able to watch back
we'll set out in all of the issues that
you've raised and therefore give
suitable context to the committee
without you needing to try and build
those into the recommendation itself
okay so if I were to suggest I just want
to get my wording right so maybe Emily
can help me here that I propose that the
the paper returned to the licensing
committee for clarity and transparency
of the tariffs and engagements aspect of
it as well for Beth for engagement
clarity and transparency of the tariff
and simplification if we can get it down
in check my offer some words to the
cabinet member so a suggested proposal
might be that the matter be referred
back to the licensing committee for
further consideration and engagement
with relevant stakeholders with a view
to simplifying and making clearer the
table of fares sounds perfect that
sounds very good Emily you've got the
job right I've got cut so hulk's and
then councillor Aarthi yeah just
thoughts I think from what Emily said I
think that that's worded
reasonably well I do stress that the
main thing here is engagement with
operators to come to or try to find a
mutual way forward try and find a mutual
way forward
we present the paper back to committee
that reflects both the wishes and the
benefits to our residents or operators
and obviously to the council thank you
Kathir Arthi it was really just to agree
with what our chief executive has said
let's leave it up to licensing to sorted
out gonna send it back to them and see
what they come back to us with yeah okay
right we've had the wording provided by
Emily customer malluci are you I think
now we move to I propose that we
withdraw the paper yeah and if somebody
can second me I'll second you on that
thank you so Claire do we take a vote on
on that withdrawn before we vote on
Emily's did you propose we don't need to
do we okay if I can remember the new
proposal that I proposed that the paper
returns to the licensing committee it
was Emily do you want to send those
words to to castle lvc how will it come
chair if we can just take the proposal
as suggested by the monitoring officer
Ryan will pick up the exact wording from
the transcript of the meeting right fine
thank you okay so do you propose that
custom lvc I do and I second that
yeah can you take a vote please yes
thank you to council our fee for
councillor Busby fool councillor Davis
for council halt or councillor Mel VC or
Council Osborne for councillor Parker
cool and council award for Thank You
chair that's unanimous thank you thank
you everyone that was quite a useful
debate I felt and
hope you will have a way forward soon
that will satisfy everyone right moving
on to the next item on the agenda that's
paper BC a 1956 CCTV arrangements in
Sudbury and Hadley and I'd like to call
on councillor Davis to introduce this
please yeah thank you very much can you
all hear me okay yeah great this report
summarizes the current challenges and
impacts of an obsolete CCTV system in
Sudbury and Hadley the options available
to the council as developed by an
officer working group and most
importantly the conversations and the
agreements reached with both our Town
Council's as these options have been
developed further there is consensus
among the partnership that investment is
necessary that a modern CCTV system in
both towns would support the visions of
prosperity for Sudbury and Hadley and
plans that would help them to deliver a
vibrant economy and thriving visitor
destination both towns have identified
CCTV infrastructure as one of the means
to deter and reduce crime and disorder
assessments antisocial behavior
enforcement activity improved public
perceptions of the town centres an
assisstant attracts an inward investment
this view is shared by the police who
have been working with us as we develop
our approach it is important for cabinet
to note that both Town Council's are
willing to enter into a formal
partnership with the council's and to
contribute to its annual running costs
this would be an unprecedented
arrangement the combat the culmination
of conversation has been going on since
all autumn and I'd like to place on
record mark my thanks to the time and
commitment for all these negotiations
with various officers David Clarke from
the communities team in particular my
fellow council - Janos Bourne who has
worked really hard in Sudbury and both
Mike Fraser and Katherine Grandin in
Hadley I think it's important to note
those as well as the police and of
course the Town Council members of staff
cabinet will see that officers have
considered four different options
moving the system all together in effect
turning it off keeping things as they
are but it says except in the system
will fail at some point soon carrying
out partial upgrades to the camera
within the current control center at
Sudbury police station and the preferred
option of upgrading the CCTV equipment
to the most up-to-date and modern
specification but also transfer and the
monitoring and maintenance to West
Suffolk Council who have full complied
control center we've explained that
currency TV systems were installed in
2000 it comprises 24 fixed cameras 17 in
submarines 7 in Hadley and they are
mainly based at the to town centers we
have had a cohort of volunteers since
2000 and monitored however there's been
three volunteers left and recruitment of
all volunteers has always been
problematic and that there are various
options that we can go forward to in
terms of the financing and this would
include using SIL and as I said the town
councils of offered to help with those
as well and I'm happy to answer and deal
with any questions Thank You councillor
may I have a seconder for for this
councillor Osborn right questions
councillor Aarthi no I was actually
raising my hand to second it but whilst
I'm talking I just like to say I think
it's fantastic that we're gonna get this
sorted out and I fully support it money
coming from sale money coming from
capital reserves whatever yeah it's it's
a good idea Thank You councillor Osborn
it's gone
cancel hold yeah thank you I just like
to credit counselor Davis on this paper
I think it is long overdue and I think
by modernizing this it will help and
reassure residents certainly in the town
centers that they've got protection
during the evening and during the day
and at night time one other thing I
disliked it to ask the council Davis is
will there be some provision for mobile
cameras for our industrial estates where
unfortunately we do have crime and at
the moment they're not protected at all
by CCTV so can I have some clarity that
both in Hadley and Sudbury there will be
the option to have mobile cameras that
will protect our businesses ah yeah this
is something the police have asked for
as well because obviously it's a lot
easier for them to be able to use the
mobile cameras in hot spots as it were
away from the actual town centers but
that doesn't detract from the actual
town center CCTV but it's something
we're working very closely with with the
police
Thank You Chancellor Busby yes the
effort in terms of funding is there any
money that we can get from the police
since it seems to seems to be to their
benefit as much as anybody's yeah yeah
you're more than welcome to try David
loads of money recently I mean well I
think mr. pasmo obviously understands
the importance of CTV in various areas
but that they are extremely short and
obviously although it's not a statutory
requirement by the council's is
something we work very closely with
because as I mentioned it in the little
preamble it is about the vision and
prosperity of the town of those
particular towns as well councillor
Osborne yeah Thank You mr. chairman I
would like to give thanks to the office
as well for their hard work in bringing
this forward and in particular
councillor Davis who has worked
tirelessly to make sure that this comes
forward in a reasonable time so thank
you for that Derek I'm very pleased to
see this coming forward for obvious
reason
I've been trying to get this agreed for
several years now so I'm really pleased
that this has now come to cabinet
I would also counselor halters meant
made reference to mobile cameras I think
this is a really excellent idea
I know house that have got a similar
system and they also we could use them
in Sudbury for hot spots but they also
loan them out at a charge to their local
parish councils to use in their
particular areas as well so there would
be a possible stream of revenue from
that as well
secondly can I just mention Derek that
it's thin I understand that the contract
once this is approved today which
hopefully it will be the contract would
take 12 to 18 months is there any way
that we can progress this so that the
contract is much quicker than that Thank
You mr. chairman
yeah well hey we got the chief executive
on board and Tom so perhaps they'll be
able to to make sure that it happens to
be quicker but of course these are
complex legal documents that our legal
team have to deal with so I would love
to see a lot lot quicker but there's a
lot of different parties involved so it
may not be that that simple
thanks guys to Davis Castle whole
question Castle Davis or and that that's
concerning the the costs and obviously
is this is not cheap and the setup costs
are quite considerable the running costs
are quite considerable and it's is that
some big town council has agreed to
allocate ten thousand pounds a year
towards running costs and Hadley town
council sis have provided similar
undertakings I don't know if that means
ten thousand pounds or that they will
contribute to running costs at an
indeterminate amount but is there a
chance of actually getting those two
Town Council's to certainly force ugly
to contribute contribute more ten
thousand in terms of the overall costs
is a fairly small amount yet that the
town will benefit quite considerably
from this
it I would have thought that it's
something that we could reasonably
expect them to contribute a
significantly increased amount of money
rather than just ten thousand pounds
they are obviously as we know able to
change their preset and in ways that we
can't with with our council tax so I
hope have we gone back to approach
Sudbury to to ask them for more yeah I
wouldn't be able to presume to talk
about somebody's budget I think that
that is something that maybe John [ __ ]
answer all but certainly the Town
Council but what I would say is of
course SIL will come out of a
Beiber's money but also the the various
councils that have their own particular
SIL money so I'm sorry I can't give you
a better answer than that no it's
something we could go back to Sudbury
and ask them for more well I think David
Clarke has done some really good
negotiates in any way it's certainly
something that we could discuss pick up
and take forward well I think with the
paper as it is you know if we agree with
this today and then obviously the finer
details will be dealt with as we go
forward
thank you councillor Osborne Thank You
mr. chairman obviously I'm not in a
position that maybe cabinet to speak on
behalf of the town council I have been
present at meetings where they have
discussed this funding and I can assure
you that they would not be prepared to
increase that amount of ten thousand
pounds I think which is going to be
their contribution at this point
obviously it's open to discussions at
later stage I know they're looking for
some sort of service level agreement but
I think there would be a reluctance from
the town council to increase that
contribution okay councillor Parker yeah
just on that theme I think sure I don't
think we need to get too bogged down in
there at this stage to be honest only
because the you know the the application
from Syl ought to take up
the lion's share of this application I
would have thought but interestingly on
that just as a matter of interest will
that be presumably that'll be a Baber
only application for sale or would that
would that be some sort of hybrid
application Jim doing name well I think
possibly this to answer councilor
Busby's point earlier on obviously the
police can dip into Scylla as well or
make application so I think it would be
probably be a hybrid I'm not saying
definitively the police but certainly
from Baber we would know I think Tom's
on the line he may be able to throw some
more light on that as anticipated for so
monies would come from Baber and the
system would be owned by Baber
unless we get steer from councillors
that you'd like to join arrangement in
terms of ownership but that hasn't been
something that either Town Council have
kind of really jumped out I think they
were they were okay to put a revenue
contribution towards it but weren't
seeking longer-term ownership of the
equipment itself so the SIL bid will be
for the capital equipment solely for the
cameras the wiring the high-speed
broadband links and those kind of things
so be for the physical infrastructure
and then the revenue costs will come
from an arrangement between Bebo Cyprian
Hadley okay thank you
right if there are no more questions
then we can move to avert I think Claire
okay once again for against to abstain
councillor our fee for council FSB
councillor Davis bought councillor Holtz
for council mov ac for cats lot Osborn
for councillor Parker thought and
council award for that's unanimous thank
you chair thanks Claire
right we're moving on to the last item
and and for that we have to exclude the
public as it's a confidential item and
so to consider whether pursuant to part
one of schedule 12a of the Local
Government Act 1972 the public should be
excluded from the meeting for the
business specified below in the agenda
on the grounds that if the public were
present during this item is likely that
there would be disclosure to them of
exempt information as indicated against
the item point of order chair castle
Parker artists their point of order do
we have to exclude the public or do we
have to take vote on whether the public
should be excluded we were taking a vote
on excluding the public so so the author
of the report proposed that in part two
is satisfied that the public interest in
maintaining exemption outweighs the
public interest in in disclosing the
information so can we go to a vote to
move into confidential session please
okay
Thank You chair councilor a fee for
Chancellor Busby fool councillor Davis
poor councillor Holt for cancelling a VC
for councilor Osborne for councilor
Parker for and councillor Ward for
right I will ask Rob to confirm when we
are in private session thank you
[Music]
you
you